NOW THEY DID NOT.
KRISTEN HOLMES, CNN, WASHINGTON.
>>> LET'S CONTINUE ON THE TOPIC.
A DEFENSE ATTORNEY IS JOINING
US.
WHAT LEGAL QUESTIONS DO YOU SEE
IN THE TAX RETURNS?
>> ALL THE ISSUES THAT HAVE BEEN
FLAGGED IN THE REPORTING AS WELL
AS WHAT WAS BROUGHT OUT IN THE
"NEW YORK TIMES" AND THE JOINT
COMMITTEE ON TAXATION, THESE
KINDS OF VALUATIONS OF HIS
BUSINESSES, THE PERFECT MATCHING
OF EXPENSES TO REVENUE TO MAKE
SURE HE PAY NOT INCOME TAXES,
HOW HE WOULD INFLATE VALUES OF
PROPERTIES IN NEW YORK, THESE
ALL WARRANT FURTHER
INVESTIGATION.
THAT MAY ALREADY BE HAPPENING.
NO REASON WHY DOJ COULDN'T HAVE
BEEN LOOKING AT THIS EARLIER.
BUT UNLIKELY -- I MEAN, I THINK
THAT THEY LACK THE APPETITE TO
TAKE ON ANOTHER TRUMP
INVESTIGATION.
I THINK IT POINTS OUT THE LACK
OF COURAGE.
IT IS A SMALL FAMILY OWNED
BUSINESS.
SMALL STEP TO CHARGE TRUMP AS
WELL.
BUT HE CHOSE TO DERAIL THAT
INVESTIGATION.
MY QUESTION IS WHY AREN'T MORE
LOOKING AT THIS.
>> AND THERE IS A QUESTION
WHETHER THE TAX RETURNS SHOW
THAT TRUMP MAY HAVE DISGUISED
GIFTS TO HIS CHILDREN.
TELL US WHAT THAT WOULD MEAN AND
HOW DIFFICULT THAT WOULD BE TO
PROVE.
>> IT WOULDN'T BE TOO DIFFICULT
TO PROVE ONCE YOU GOT
EVERYBODY'S RECORDS.
USUALLY WHAT HAPPENS WITH A GIFT
TAX VIOLATION, SOMEBODY HAS TO
PAY TAXES FOR IT.
I THINK HERE IT WOULD BE PLUGGED
INTO THE BIG PICTURE OF ALL OF
THE QUESTIONABLE ISSUES GOING ON
AND THAT COULD BECOME A CRIMINAL
TAX FRAUD CASE WHERE HE IS
EVADING MILLIONS IF NOT HUNDREDS
OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS FOR
TAXES.
AND THERE IS A POPULAR NOTION
THE IRS LIKES TO GO AFTER
SMALLER TARGETS AND WE'RE KIND
OF SEEING THAT TO BE TRUE.
BUT ON THE OTHER HAND WHEN YOU
HAVE A SERIES OF VIOLATIONS
ADDING UP TO THIS KIND OF LOSS,
THAT IS WHAT COMES CROSSES THE
LINE FROM CIVIL TO CRIMINAL.
>> AND HE HAD FOREIGN BANK
ACCOUNTS INCLUDING AN ACCOUNT IN
CHINA BETWEEN 2015 AND 2017.
DOES THAT RAISE ANY CONCERNS
WITH YOU?
>> IT ISN'T NECESSARILY A
CONCERN ABOUT LEGALITY.
I MEAN, PEOPLE DOING BUSINESS IN
OTHER COUNTRIES WILL HAVE
FOREIGN BANK ACCOUNTS.
I THINK WHAT THIS REALLY FLAGS
FOR ME IS WHAT A BOTCHED JOB THE
IRS DID IN NOT CONDUCTING THE
AUDITS AND ALSO HOW IMPORTANT IT
IS THAT CANDIDATES FOR PRESIDENT
DO CONTINUE THIS PRACTICE OF
RELEASING THE RETURNS.
BECAUSE THAT IS SOMETHING
IMPORTANT FOR THE PRESS, FOR THE
PEOPLE TO QUESTION WHAT KIND OF
FOREIGN INTERESTS DID YOU HAVE.
THEY MIGHT BE INNOCUOUS, BUT
PEOPLE SHOULD KNOW.
AND CONGRESS PROBABLY SHOULD
REALLY PASS A LAW REQUIRING THAT
DI